the man who presented him for
enshrinement the Pro Football Hall of
Fame longtime Philadelphia Eagle now
executive vice president of football
operations of the National Football
League Troy Vincent on the show how are
you good how you doing rich I'm good
thank you
right yeah me too me too did you know
all that about Brian Troy yes sir
those were those were the discussions
that we had on throughout the time that
as we were leading up into the gold
jacket dinner and Saturday night to hear
Brian now publicly talk about his
concerns his issues it it was refreshing
because as as people as believers his
testimony saves lives as we always say
when we go through trials and
tribulations in life they're not for us
they're for someone else and on the
biggest stage the conversation is that
we used to have inside the sauna the
steam steam room the cold tub in that in
the weight room and our lockers he told
the world about it and he told the world
about overcoming coming that and we
always used to always talk about your
testimony is not for you as for someone
else and he shared it which was which
was amazing and I'm just so thankful I'm
proud of him and I didn't know that he
was going to go there as we were
preparing and driving over hey Doc you
got your notes and stuff ready enriched
he gave me a little piece of paper a
ball that piece of paper but just a few
knows someone or not and I'm saying in
my mind he can't go on stage which is
there's there is no way I mean I'm in
the back seat and I'm seeing him getting
him I said he can't go on stage with
this and he looked back we prayed and he
looked back and he said sure I'm allowed
a spirit to lead me today and that's
what that's what we saw he was
unbelievable Troy and and then again to
just talk about how he was planning his
own undoing I mean they they cut away to
his wife was just shaking her head when
when he when he
with real hmm it was real it was and it
was daily and this is what you come in
and you talk and you say hey man what's
up and it go today's not a good day or
first thing in the morning hey what's up
I didn't see you and he was say T today
not a good death and then that's when we
would just alright let's talk about it
without judgment but it was God and then
thinking about okay you talked about
greatness you talked about being a
family man you talked about being a
great father great son it's not our time
we can't talk about taking our own life
let's talk about let's talk about how we
get over this mountain and that's what
it was it was that way all eight years
we played together
Troy Vinson here on the Rich Eisen show
after after a very moving induction
ceremony also serving here kindly enough
on the Rich Eisen show for the Honda
inside a report Troy let me ask you this
then when it all comes down to it what
did it instrument mean to Brian Dawkins
what we threw that one is it solidified
it solidified the football part of his
life and if you heard in his opening
remarks he talked about football is what
I did it wasn't Who I am
because growing up that's how he was
defined at brains high school that's how
he was defined at Clemson with no no
outlet so giving closure to the football
sigh because he's he talked about what
God wants to do with him in his next
phase of his life it's about him
identifying with people who were just
thinking just his same thoughts males
and females who were going through the
same exact thing that he was going and
to be able to share that on that stage
rich when he sat back when he sat back
on stage next to me when I looked at him
he was completely dry and his eyes was
open meaning he was vibrant again there
was a weight that was on him you can you
saw it coming over you saw it during the
week some Antonis but he shared and it
was unfiltered and that's how you change
lives that's living a life of purpose I
just talked to him about now
he's still in it can't with his mother
and I asked him okay it'd be how you
feeling and he said again man it feel
like a weight lifting over over just
weight is lifted off of my shoulder I
think I can help more people I think
I've been released to help more people
and this was two hours ago and I think
that's what it means to all as you heard
each of the individuals talk about
trials tribulations what the game does
when we call that the greater gain but
in particular for Bryant to share that
now God can use you that's the greater
gain what was it like just being there
because so much was discussed this week
about who wasn't there and tío and what
the weekend means and is even word that
Canton the folks at Canton and
hall-of-famer thinking about making
future candidates sign a like a pledge
to appear in order for their and hope
selection to go for so rich I was saying
I was there all week and I obviously as
a work week for myself and this week I
had a personal engagement involvement
and this is what I would say because I
my wife was asking me how many times did
you how many times you cry you know and
don't be out there boohoo and so on and
so forth enriched it started frankly I
saw the best in America doing the parade
so what were you talking about I said if
you're in that car and you're going down
those two those two miles there's
hundreds of thousands of people rooting
for people that they never rooted for
about that they've never on any Sunday
Monday or Thursday it doesn't happen
that's fact you're right and and and to
see I saw multiple people with Emma
Smith Jersey on stand up and say Bryant
today we honor you that's the best of
America I saw disabled us all you said
all white you saw black you saw that
King knows or so everybody some
law-enforcement men and women you saw
first responders they came out for one
reason to celebrate
the game and the greats so that we could
just it was that way all weekend at
people of Ken their service their
hospitality it frankly was an example of
the best of America and it was another
it was another reminder of the
importance and the power of our sport I
saw it firsthand just driving and I
couldn't contain myself because I'm
saying all of the stuff that we see
going on each and every day looking for
leadership questioning who we are
questioning society values I saw it in
Canton Ohio
I saw people rooting for folks they
never reach for I saw men and women
sitting next to each other on lawn
chairs cheering for the best of Troy
Vincent NFL executive VP here on the
Rich Eisen show as you said it's a work
week and you know the Hall of Fame vets
returning Hall of Famers are the alphas
of the alpha male group they are no
wallflowers I'm wondering if they gave
you any thoughts on football operations
that you're in charge of in any way
shape or form in the NFL Troy well
always and I so my I would say the folks
that I deal with constantly mostly our
legends Hall of Famers included or
coaches owners and general managers and
each of them because many have been
involved in all of our endeavors as we
look at rules as we look at rule changes
points of emphasis in particular Ronnie
Willie Lanier Curtis Martin Aeneas coach
Madden and that group in muj Willie
McGinest
so those gold Jack is there they're
there with us every step of the way as
they always talk about we got to
preserve this great game how do we make
it better and so we talk about every
element again from the values to making
sure that we protect the quarterback to
making sure we don't over officiate we
don't under eight and they're the best
of the best so their insight is
invaluable in Commissioner myself and
others the competition committee with
rich rich McKay they're an intricate
part of how we view the game and see
and it's not one said well they're out
date no they're not outdated errors is
relevant they watch more tape than just
a normal thing so their input in their
eye their football eye their intuition
their instincts is invaluable to what we
do so let's get into a couple of
situations here then Troy the penalties
for the violation of the rule we're
lowering your head to initiate and make
contact with your helmet against an
opponent three flags in the hall of fame
game that left a lot of folks
hand-wringing over the demise of
football as we know it Troy
what do you say to those who say that
this rule is going to ruin football I
would say pause for a second because we
said the same conversation took place
when we implemented the defenseless
player whoo and the purpose of the why
is we want to remove the helmet from the
head take the head out of the game we
want to protect players from unnecessary
risk and through this process talking to
our coaches our players even fans are
Hall of Famers our owners we had been
looking at the data the science the
research all of the engineering input
from everybody the video says that we
have to alter this game and the helmet
should never be used as a weapon that's
that's the origin of how we got here now
the the actual rule itself we had to
actually to collect calls law one in the
first quarter one in the third on the
use of the helmet we're still as we make
our training camp training camp visits
there's still a little bit of
clarification that we need to just work
out from a crew to crew but there were
two correct calls during the game we had
one incorrect call where there was a
blend of the defenseless player and the
use of the helmet rule so which one was
that was that the second flag or the
third flag one would Jackson coming
across the middle looked that was it
that was the fourth one that was in the
photo it was a fourth it was in the
fourth
quarter there was a UN are there was
unnecessary roughness on a defenseless
player call the contact to the head or
neck area directly announce unnecessary
roughness not you not use of helmet so
the Bennett Jackson hit in the fourth
quarter you think should not have been a
foul
hello comes out to it like his helmet
was in front of the plate row it did not
look like he was leading with his helmet
looked like he he led with his shoulder
and after the game he said that one of
the officials told him it's preseason we
have to throw the flag in it and we're
going to see flags don't because this is
how players and coaches are just we
adjust based off of the way the set the
fouls are being called in that fourth
quarter in that particular play could
there could be some contact that it had
Necker that at that chin area we in
pre-season we want them to we don't want
to say I guess it's over officiate but
we want to be consistent we want to be
consistent and we're still working in
this particular area rich we've come a
long way with our educational videos
there's some language that we need to to
just clean up as we go into frankly week
one of preseason that's what preseason
is for for the officials as well to get
it right to make sure that every player
understand we've seen it just in the
first preseason game just that one just
that one game we saw players adjusting
making an effort to keep that head out
of the game okay so and and what came
out of Philadelphia is well that
officials that came to explain the rule
we're not on the same page I know you
addressed that locally in a radio
station in Philadelphia I'm wondering if
you could address that here real quick
since that's something we talked what we
saw an interview look at you listen to
Doug Peterson coach Peterson's comments
and he just walked at one the the the
reporters that were asking the question
walking through the process and actually
was on record of saying this is in the
best interest of the game now what
happened in the in the players room as
the officials were walking through it
there was a he didn't draw the line of
defenseless player
the use of the helmet and he blended - -
without saying okay
we're going to go from use of helmet
we're now going to talk about the
defenseless player and he blended - -
which could create doubt cloudiness
great we got to remove all of the gray
and you heard the players expressed that
so it was it was it was an
interpretation it was a blending of two
different rules and that's what we have
to be clear on as we go through and we
had some webinars last week so after
that came out got the officials back on
the phone last Wednesday and Thursday
and we talked about what actually took
place in Philly for clarification
purposes as they continue their Club
visits and work through pre-season Troy
thanks for the time really appreciate
you sharing some insights from this
weekend and obviously something that's
got a lot of a lot of football fans up
in arms confused or or concerned about I
really appreciate it
rich we'll get there okay if the fans
can just understand we really did the
effort here is to protect players of
unnecessary risk and this is at every
level we got to get to head out of the
game and the players will adjust and the
coaches will as well right Roy thanks
again really appreciate at least do this
again soon safe travels around the
country there you got it at Detroit
Vincent NFL executive vice president
former Walter Payton Man of the Year and
a 15 year veteran in the NFL the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience